aquí en Ciudad Juárez se estima que hay
unos 35.000 migrantes asentados en los
diferentes campamentos junto al muro
metálico que instaló Estados Unidos y
Que los separa de la otra ciudad
fronteriza El Paso Texas aunque también
se registran masivas concentraciones de
migrantes en otras ciudades como Reynosa
Matamoros o Tijuana en Juárez el flujo
migratorio ha crecido exponencialmente
en los últimos días dado el rumor que ha
corrido entre ellos de que la
solicitudes de asilos están procesando
de una manera más expedita más diligente
y esto de cara al final del título 42 la
política antimigración de la era Trump
que ha permitido expulsar a miles de
migrantes pero cuya expiración será a
las 11:59 de la noche hora del este de
mañana jueves 11 de mayo Qué pasará
después pues esa es la gran incógnita e
incertidumbre que corre no solo entre
los miles de migrantes sino también
entre los agentes de aduana y los de la
patrulla fronteriza de acuerdo con el
departamento de seguridad nacional se
estima que el número de migrantes que
cruza irregularmente la frontera se
duplicará de 6.000 a 12.000 pero es esta
misma institución la que le advierte a
los migrantes que ahora sobre ellos
pesará el título 8 una política de vieja
Data que les pueda acarrear además de la
expulsión una prohibición de admisión al
país de al menos cinco años una política
fronteriza que afectará sobre todo a los
migrantes más avezados aquellos que no
se entreguen y soliciten un proceso de
asilo pero que confían en que puedan
huir de la patrulla fronteriza que los
persiga